-Hello, Congresswoman Demings.
-Good evening.
It's great to be with you.
-Thank you so much for coming on
the show and talking to me.
I want to get into everything
with you
because you're such
an interesting person.
I read somewhere that you held
your first office
in sixth grade.
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
-Oh, my God.
So, look, first through
fifth grade,
I went to an all-black school,
first through fifth.
And then in sixth grade,
our school was integrated,
so I was transferred to a school
that was much closer to my home.
I grew up in
a rural part of Jacksonville.
And I was selected
to be a school patrol.
And, Jimmy, I took my job
as a school patrol
very, very seriously.
It was supposed to be limited to
helping children, you know,
maybe cross the street
or cross the parking lot,
and just standing there
with my orange badge on,
looking official.
But I really carried my job
to the bus.
And if kids were misbehav--
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, yeah!
You put them in their place!
I love it! Oh, my God!
And look at you now. See, kids?
-I'm surprised they didn't do
a stakeout and wait for me
on the playground or something.
-Yeah. I know, yeah.
-Look now.
-Look at you now.
With everything that's going on,
I mean, there's so much
happening in this world.
And gosh, I just want to
first off and say I think
you've done a great job
with everything that's going on,
with Black Lives Matter
kind of putting you
in an interesting position.
-What happened to
George Floyd --
and let me say this as
a former law enforcement officer
who did the job 27 years --
I grew up
in the Orlando police
department,
worked my way up
through the ranks
to become their first woman
chief of police.
It was a job that I loved
and a job that I felt like
I was really
making a difference.
-Sure.
-But what I do know is
what happened to George Floyd
was brutal.
It was senseless. It was murder.
And the persons responsible
are being and should be held
accountable.
What happened to Breonna Taylor,
we need to look at our policies
at law enforcement agencies
all over this country.
No-knock warrants,
I'm very familiar with them.
They always been high-risk.
They're dangerous.
And so when we look at
the things that we're doing
or proposing in the George Floyd
Justice and Policing Act,
we're dealing with, you know,
who we hire.
We're dealing with training.
We're dealing with policy
and trying to develop
a national standard.
So whether you're a 10-person
agency in a small town
or a 36,000-person agency
in a big city,
there will be some national
standards that really will help
to govern how
police departments operate.
And that's a good thing.
-All those years
as police chief,
is there something
that you're most proud of?
-When I was appointed chief
at the end of 2007,
crime was at an all-time high
in Orlando.
I knew that
if I had not been successful
in reducing the crime rate,
we know what people
would have said.
"First woman chief, oh, my God,
she can't handle that job.
And my God,
she's a black woman too."
Perhaps they may have said that.
But instead of focusing on
the crisis,
I chose to focus on
the opportunity.
I reorganized the department.
I disbanded some units
that were pretty dysfunctional.
And we worked very closely
with our community,
and we were able to reduce
violent crime by over 40%.
-Wow.
-I'm very proud of that.
-Is there something you wish
you did a better job of?
-You know, as a public servant,
and I won't just limit it
to police work,
I would hope that every public
servant would say to themselves,
when asked that question, "Yeah,
I wish I would have done more."
I really wish I would have
focused more on training
within the police department.
We focused a lot on training.
Don't get me wrong.
We trained in some areas
four times more
than the state required.
But in terms of
de-escalation training,
one of the things that I used to
say to the men and women
all the time when I was
the chief was that
number one, you have a lot of
equipment around your waist.
The best weapon that you have is
the good brain that you have.
-Yes.
-"Use it. Always use it."
Our ability
to communicate with people.
When we talk about de-escalation
skills, that's all that is.
It might have a fancy name,
but it's the ability
to not be rushed,
not respond to the next call
before you finish this one,
but really take your time
and use the best weapon
that you have been issued,
your brain and the gift of gab
to de-escalate the situation.
Now let me say this.
You can't do it on everybody.
There are some people who are
just looking for the fight.
Right? And if you show up
in a police uniform,
that's the one
they've been looking for.
-Yeah.
-But to have focused more
on de-escalation training,
I think, is always a win-win.
And that's definitely something
that we are doing
with the George Floyd
Justice and Policing Act.
And I believe
that's a good thing.
-Before we go, and thank you
so much again for doing this,
I know you're very busy.
Congresswoman, you are
on the short list
of maybe being
the vice president.
As the little girl who is the,
you know, the school patrol,
the 11-year-old Val, would you
ever think this is possible?
-What my parents helped me
to see or what they made
their seven children
and their baby daughter believe
was that only in America
it's possible.
And if we look historically,
America has let us down
in some areas.
But as a nation, we've always
seemed to have the ability
to stand up and get it right.
Whether that's
the women's right movement,
the civil rights movement,
the voting rights movement,
marriage equality
and equal rights,
we've always had the ability
to get it right.
And so I do believe that
only in America
can that little black girl
who grew up the daughter
of a maid and a janitor,
served as the school patrol,
be on a short list for Vice
President of the United States.
I'm honored and humbled by
the possibility.
-Congresswoman, thank you
so much for coming on our show
and talking to me.
I would love to
talk to you more.
And I would love to see you in
person one day, hopefully soon.